Short and sweet number 13. There are four criteria that must be met in order to make wine
which is touched by a non-Jew to be forbidden both for drinking and for benefit. The first one is that
when they touch the wine they have to have intent to touch the wine. The second is that they must
know that the liquid that they are touching is wine. They have to be touching the wine for the
sake of the wine, not for some other reason. For example, removing the foam from the top of the
And finally, they have to have shaken the wine.
If there is a scenario where one of these four criteria are missing, and the non-Jew is a bona fide idol worshiper,
the wine is permitted to benefit, but it would still be forbidden to drink.
If one of the factors are missing and the Jew is not an idol worshiper, for example, a Muslim,
then the wine would be permitted even to drink.
The question is, what about a situation where the person is a Christian?
So then we mentioned that according to the Shulchan Aruch, Christians are considered idol worshippers, and all that we just mentioned previously about an idol worshipper would apply to a Christian.
We said, though, however, the Ramah holds that Christians nowadays do not laibate, and therefore they are not considered to be idol worshippers.
The Shach himself says that the Ramah is only lenient, sorry, the Shach is lenient even without a loss of money, but the Shach says in the case of a Christian, we should not be, Megad, we should not be lenient if there is not a loss of money.
The present custom in regards to this, about a Christian touching a non-mubishal wine, the Svaradim do hold that they are considered idol worshippers, and the Ashkenazim generally follow the Shach, and therefore would only allow wine which is poured by a Christian in the case of a great loss of money.
We then discussed some other cases where it would be permissible to drink the wine, according to everyone.
If, let's say, the non-Jew came into indirect contact with the wine, and also it was unintentional contact, that would be a case that would be permissible.
Another case that everyone allows, if the non-Jew just touches the bottle, but doesn't move it, doesn't pick it up, that would be permissible.
If they would shake a closed bottle, that would also be permissible.
We discussed a case where, let's say, they shook the bottle without lifting it, so that the Shulchan Aruch did say the wine is prohibited, while the Rama would say it's permitted if there is a great loss.